I'm looking for someone dynamic to lead
any volunteers do you need the bathroom
Bridget Bridget always seems to me much
wonderful paradox between utter
hopelessness and incredible competence
her optimism and her determination to
succeed in spite of her failings is
inspiring I'm pregnant I've got another
baby huh everything is completely under
control she's not a loser she's still
funny and she's not just a stooge either
she's witty so you have no idea which of
us is actually the varlon no it's all
very confusing she's not perfect and she
doesn't intend to be but she's you know
trying to find her way there bears
equally likely so dude bring along the
father if you can work out which one he
is brunette is better but clean Bridget
than i can imagine anyone being because
she's got the capacity to act that
slightly scatty thing which she isn't at
all oh she was a tarnished nurse to her
all the potential for humiliation which
is always lurking she still plans on
awkward comedy is my favorite on-screen
and off comes really naturally to me I
enjoy it especially when Sharon is
around the corner laughing and shouting
out how I make it more clumsy we work on
that amount just how far we can go with
her klutzy or dysfunction or she is but
most of these the things that she does
are based on somebody who knows life it
blows my mind I mean as far as I'm
concerned this has been worth coming
back just to see her do
Renee is Bridget Jones she plays it in a
very sympathetic way because I think
that kindness oozes out of her she was
definitely the right person for it and
it couldn't have happened without her
this time